[Musique]
denis julien est hachette emblématique
du coin installé au bord du marais il me
reçoit pour me faire déguster sa
spécialité les couilles dan
les couilles dan du berry pas
d'inquiétude c'est beaucoup plus subtil
et beaucoup plus fins j'avoue que je ne
connais pas cette spécialité culinaire
berrichonne mais denis julien fervent
défenseur des traditions locales va tout
vous expliquer
lui est venue à la course hier le
restaurant de dennis dennis dennis ça va
ça va la flandre ou alors on m'a dit que
je devais goûter une de ses spécialités
ils m'ont fait croire pendant des jours
et des jours l'équipe technique là que
les couilles dan c'était vraiment dairy
queen anne brenon et j'étais pas bien
mais non on est sympa avec thé zen
malgré garder les mille apprenants denis
là on est au bord des marais oui c'est
quoi ton rapport nous sommes en avec les
marines bourg d'abord sunna la campagne
super riches mais non verrouillée
l'environnement et
génial tous les jours la nature change
d'aspect desjardins il y en a aucun qui
se ressemble toi tu mélanges la nature
et on s'est un peu le paradis à bord on
se fait des couilles allez on se fait
des couilles ses buts il a dit qu'est ce
que c'est vraiment les kodan pour
devrait alors céder au poché donc on
fait une sauce avec du vin rouge des
oignons échalotes de l'ail du thym du
laurier longtemps fait sa seconde
attaque en lapin ou moules voilà et donc
c'est pour ça que il ya eu quelques mois
la mairie qui s'est dit et si j'appelais
sa découverte j'arrive à jojo rien de la
vie en cuisine je vois un peu l'équipe
voir le crew alors on maquille on à
kevin quand je suis rentré j'ai vu kevin
au bar kevin linda à cliquer ici et
madame mouna va faire de la musique
ensemble ça va on va faire une chanson
qui va s'appeler si tu veux des couilles
de
hockey featuring avec kevin sa voix
rauque est trop rapide et trop rapide de
nickel vitesse chez party dire bonjour à
l'équipe cinq minutes je reviendrai
c'est déjà pressés alors oui parce qu'il
faut qu'il reste que le jeune soit
coulant sentir tout pas que ce soit des
oeufs durs quand on perd cela le jaune
il est faux qui ce qui serait offerte
voilà et une cuillère et on peut
déguster
régler les petits brins de persil sur
les réseaux sociaux qui casse le poignet
et après il fait
et ça ne s'est strictement rien
alors moi je voulais montrer ses photos
voilà ça c'est des photos de celui ci à
l'origine ces rites et un bas et dans
les années 20 il on monter une
guinguette les photos date de 1932 les
gens venaient ici pour gâcher
on a eu plein de papis mamies qui nous
ont expliqué qu'ils étaient géniales et
il a les mêmes pendant la guerre il ya
eu des balkans des et on sait comment ça
s'appelait le pas le nom du bar à
l'époque on n'a pas le nom au dessus au
début le bars et le comptoir de
maraîchers redémarrer au lieu-dit la
corse il y avait à partir des années 20
et calque ainsi appelé la continuer mais
ça qu'est ce que c'est des couilles dan
sculpté par un copain qui s'appelle jean
marie borda ça va avec eux ceux des
spécialités de la démarrer mais très
belles sculptures bravo jean marie borda
bravo pour cette sculpture très réussi
c'est très réussi on voit bien les des
couilles qui vont forcément les les
oreilles de dollars
merci denis merci au revoir et cabinet
et mon futur bing ah oui le futur il
avait oublié kevin oui on va faire ça
proprement
musique maestro
si tu veux des couilles dan bien chez
denis julien au bord du marais de
bourges il est cuisinier bien si tu veux
des colis dan vient donc dans le berry
et si t'aime pas à l'écrou ya la tête de
veau rosé